in today's video i'm gonna share with
you my 2020 holiday gift guide for dads
who love games
hard to believe but 2020 is thankfully
just about over and on the bright side
this means the holidays are right around
the corner
so for all the significant others kids
or other family members out there
looking for that perfect gift for your
video game loving dad
i've got you covered and we're starting
right now people of the international
retro record tour here for meeting for
the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
it's always baffled me to hear my wife
say that it's difficult to buy me gifts
seems pretty obvious to me but hey she's
not much of a gamer and isn't really
that into tech so i guess it kind of
makes sense and that's where today's
video comes in
we'll run through 10 gaming gift ideas
for dads and honey
if you're watching and still looking for
something to get me this year i mean
just saying
a few hints here i'll be including links
to all of these products down in the
description below
if you're interested in purchasing of
course if you have any questions feel
free to let me know down in the comments
as well
this year we have the release of two
next-gen consoles in the playstation 5
and
xbox series x there's also the xbox
series
s which is a cheaper less powerful
version of the series x
the problem here is these are going to
be insanely hard to find this holiday
season
if you haven't pre-ordered already
chances are you probably won't get one
this year
there is a third option when it comes to
consoles though and that's the nintendo
switch
the switch went through quite a shortage
of its own throughout the summer when
many of us were locked down and
quarantined
it seems that nintendo has started to
catch up with demand though and you can
usually find them in stock online at
least
at the time of this recording that could
change
there are two versions of the switch
first there's the standard version which
can be used on the go or placed in the
included dock to play on your tv
there's also the nintendo switch lite
which is a handheld only version of the
system
but it's 100 cheaper both run all the
same games and there are a ton of great
ones on the nintendo switch
zelda breath of the wild mario odyssey
and smash bros are a few of my favorites
the switch is honestly a great system
even if you plan on getting a ps5 or
xbox series x at some point
there are just so many top notch
exclusive nintendo titles that you won't
be able to play
anywhere else so what about buying games
as
gifts unless you're buying a brand new
system you may
actually want to stay away from buying
games for dads
typically when you think of buying for
gamers the first item family members
think of
is a game right makes sense here's the
problem going this route though
most dads are going to purchase the main
games they want themselves
i know for games that i'm eagerly
anticipating i usually make plans to buy
at launch or perhaps i have some sort of
trade-in deal i'm taking advantage of
so if you're thinking about going with
that approach just make sure you check
in with dad first to see what games he's
already pre-ordered
also with new consoles hitting this year
it's more important than ever to make
sure you're picking the right version of
the game
a lot of the big titles this year are
releasing on four different platforms
ps4
xbox one ps5 and xbox series x
regardless of where your gamer dad likes
to play you can always check out
accessories such as extra controllers or
headsets as well
if you're looking for an extra
controller you'll mostly want to stick
with the first party options from sony
microsoft and nintendo
for ps5 sony has also made their own
media remote
headset and charging dock for the
controllers now maybe you're looking for
something that
dad can enjoy with the kids in that case
check out mario kart live circuit this
is a new i would say kind of an
experimental title from nintendo that
uses
augmented reality technology to create a
race track
out of your home now this actually does
come with a physical
cart that will move around your home so
you want to make sure that you have at
least a decent amount of space that you
can set this up in
then as you race through your house
you'll also see the action take place
on your screen lots of fun for both kids
and parents here with this one
there's also nintendo labo which has
been out for a bit now and you can
usually find it heavily discounted
labo is an interesting idea from
nintendo that has players putting
together physical cardboard items such
as a fishing pole
which then interact with games that come
bundled in the fun with nintendo labo is
the bonding time you get with your kids
during the build process i actually have
one of these kits that my son and i have
really enjoyed putting together
and then you get to see your creation
utilized in game
speaking of new tech though if the data
in your life hasn't jumped into vr yet
now could be the time as standalone
units are getting better
and more affordable every year for this
year i'd recommend the oculus quest
2 vr headset this is a standalone vr
unit meaning you don't need an expensive
gaming pc or any other
extra hardware to use it the 64 gigabyte
unit retails for 2.99
now if you're looking for something a
little bit cheaper or maybe some
stocking stuffers here then there are a
great number of
books out there on video games console
wars by blake harris is an oft
recommended title and a great place to
start
it tells the story of the 90s rivalry
between nintendo and sega which changed
the course of video games forever
there's also the ultimate history of
video games by stephen kent which is
another solid choice
this one focuses on a much broader
history of video games spanning across
multiple companies
and games if you're looking for fiction
titles instead then check out ready
player one which was made into a major
motion picture back in 2018
now if it's too hard to choose just one
book or maybe your loved one is a big
reader then you could always look into
gifting them a subscription to
audible you can even try audible
yourself with a free one month trial to
either their plus plan or premium plus
plan
just make sure you cancel before the 30
days is up if you decide not to keep the
plan
you can find the links and all the
details down in the description
moving on to our next item we have video
game themed lego
again this is another item families can
work on as a group
my son and i love tackling projects like
puzzles or lego together
there are a couple of incredible sets
available this year including both
minecraft and mario themed sets
the mario ones are some of my favorites
because you can get creative and build
your own levels by adding on expansion
sets when you're ready
now we've talked about consoles we've
talked about games we've talked about
accessories but one of the most
important
pieces of furniture for any gamer is
going to be their chair
if you're buying for someone who games
on a tv and maybe there's not much space
or you want something that's easily
stowed away
then i highly recommend video rockers
honestly it looks like these are made
for
kids but i actually find them super
comfortable as well i'd stay away from
the more expensive ones which have like
these audio features that
you probably won't end up using and
instead focusing on something more basic
but comfortable now if you prefer to
keep the gifts coming all year long then
you may want to check out
loot crate and their loot gaming
subscription box you can gift your loved
one a 1 month
6 month or 12 month subscription now if
you're not familiar with loot crate how
it works is they send out a crate to you
each month that includes four to six
items valued at a minimum
of sixty dollars the crates may include
collectibles apparel figures and more
part of the fun is the surprise you get
when seeing the new crate arrive each
month
if you happen to be shopping for kids
this year be sure and check out my
other video featuring my top 10 nintendo
switch games for kids
as always thank you so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon